[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'avais des petites
accessoires et vêtements
voici un saut dans lequel j'ai mis des
gros qu'elle va essayer de vous le
montrer aux loyers à votre avis je vous
pose la question ce soit il remplit ou
non oui oui alors c'est vrai il allait
rentrer mais regardez bien je peux
ajouter des petits cailloux et puis tant
qu'à faire je paye ajouter aussi du
sable en tassant bien au sein contre
j'en ai même puis rajouter d'où je vais
pas le faire parce que quand je me suis
entraîné à faire cette expérience
montceau été percés j'en ai mis un petit
peu partout donc je me suis dit qu'on
allait s'épargner ça vous et moi
aujourd'hui quel est l'objet de cette
démonstration à votre avis qui n'est pas
droit
je l'a emprunté un expert américain en
gestion du temps j'ai simplement voulu
vous montrer que dans la vie si vous ne
mettez pas vos gros caillou en premier
on pourrait appeler ça vos priorités
alors il arrivera un moment où vous
n'aurez plus la place pour les mettre
parce que la place aura été pris par
d'autres choses des choses plus futiles
très tôt j'ai su qu'elle était mais gros
caillou mais j'ai perdu du temps
beaucoup de temps et c'est cette
histoire que je vais vous raconter enfin
bon je savais pas vraiment quelle formes
précises cela allait prendre mais disons
que j'ai toujours pensé que j'avais une
sorte de mission dans la vie alors rien
d'extraordinaire j'ai une vie tout à
fait normale mais j'ai toujours porté
l'idée que j'étais destiné à faire
quelque chose de ma vie professionnelle
qui me rendent heureuse qui m'épanouit
et qui l'enrichissent à cons ça une
ambition j'ai passé les trente premières
années de ma vie à m'entraîner à
atteindre cette ambition je me suis
d'abord fin et en suivant des études
plutôt longue et pas forcément choisi en
pleine conscience
et puis j'ai enchaîné les jobs les
statuts aussi j'étais s'alarmer j'ai été
freelance mais jamais j'avais cette
sensation d'être au bon endroit au bon
moment
jamais ça lui ressemble tout à fait à ma
vision d'une professionnelle heureuse et
épanouie leur verve de l'ambition et des
rêves finalement parce que c'est un
petit peu de 50 il s'agit c'est la peur
de l'échec
et je crois bien que durant toutes ces
années c'est elle qui m'a scotché elle
est terrible cette peur de l'échec parce
que elle pousse à ne rien faire allez
surtout rien changer dans ce mode
opératoire et surtout à toujours trouver
des excuses à l'extérieur pour justifier
l'inaction je vous donne un exemple je
peux pas changer de job j'ai rien
derrière
je peux pas déménager ou est-ce que
j'irai je peux pas quitter cette
personne j'ai eu trop peur de mettre des
salles
on fait alors enchaîné comme ça très
longtemps les faux problèmes
le temps passe et alors on a cette
sensation assez désagréable de passer à
côté de sa vie j'ai entendu quelque part
que c'était un sentiment partagé par un
français sur deux ça fait beaucoup
faire un petit calcul nous sommes à peu
près 100 personnes dans sept salles
aujourd'hui
ça voudrait dire que 50 d'entre nous ont
déjà éprouvé un jour ce sentiment de
passer à côté sa vie alors je vous
demanderai pas de lever la main pour l
est
stick mais moi en tout cas je fais
partie de ces 50% et un moment de ma vie
je me suis posé cette question mais
quand est ce que mon moment va arriver
quand est-ce que je vais enfin vivre
cette vie dans laquelle je me projette
depuis 6000 ans quand j'ai 30 ans j'ai
décidé que je m'étais entraîné j'ai
décidé qu'il était temps pour moi de
vivre autrement et d'être actrice
davantage que spectatrice de magie et
vous savez points ça a marché
mon secret je vais vous le dire j'ai osé
prendre des risques simplement ça s'est
passé comme ça j'imagine bien que la
seconde les chances de ma conversation
cette conversation pardon vous attendait
un changement incroyable revirement 360°
parce que c'est vrai souvent il faut une
rupture très franches dans une vie pour
prendre conscience des priorités à agir
souvent motivées par un événement
dramatique comme la perte d'un proche ou
ou une maladie en fait pour moi ça s'est
passé comme ça ça a été beaucoup plus
simple c'est une petite goutte d'eau
très futile qui a rempli mon sont pour
filer la métaphore est fini par le faire
des voiries un petit changement après
votre qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui m'aviez
a pris un tournant tout à fait
différemment
je vais vous raconter cette histoire il
ya trois ans je vivais à paris avec mon
mari et ma petite fille j'appelle un job
gagnais très bien ma vie mais dans
lequel je n'aime pas ne sais pas trop et
puis machines et les trois ans dextérité
le moment d'inscrire à l'école comme
pour beaucoup d'enfants dans ces cas-là
l'école dans laquelle nous étions
sectorisé était pas un bâtiment ce très
ancien avec donc beaucoup d'élèves y à
peu près 300 enfants et c'est vrai que
ça pouvait être un petit peu flippant
enlever du prisme et un enfant de 3 ans
est encore plus de sa mère un poil
flipper de lâcher sa progéniture dans
l'ordre j'ai pourtant inscrite pendant
que j'ai dit pensant parce que j'avais
pas vraiment d'autre choix en le disant
en temps même si je suis allé m'asseoir
dans le petit parc et pour enfants à
côté pour réfléchir à tout ça à un
moment donné mon regard a croisé celui
d'un rat immense tout trottiner entre le
toboggan tant qu'enfants et le bac à
sable c'était rien pour s'était pas
grand chose sera mais en fait il a
cristallisé toutes les frustrations
toutes les offres satisfaction que je
vivais dans ma vie à ce moment là le
soir quand je suis rentré chez moi je
m'en suis ouverte à mon mari mon mari
qui n'a peur de rien et pour qui le
changement est un ami famille est
presque intime
il m'a regardé ces posément il m'a dit
ok on déménage mutuelle chaque fois
qu'il m'a pris de court
je pensais qu'il présentait arf et il
était très sérieux
j'ai en même temps il a absolument
raison qu'est-ce qui me retenait ici
dans cette vie où je vivais un job que
j'aimais pas trop je me suis dit c'est
plutôt et puis j'avais beaucoup de mal
finalement imaginez ma fille grandir
s'épanouir dans sa vie d'enfant moi je
n'ai jamais fini plus tard alors comme
ça il ya trois ans j'ai quitté mon
jardin j'ai dit et pagnes et sur une
simple intuition et la conscience en
outre mon mari on a déménagé dans une
ville où je n'étais jamais allée de
magie mais où il me semblait bon vivre
hervé la mer à proximité c'est plutôt
chouette j'avais jamais crédit les nerfs
en tout cas faut vivre selon toi les
vacances donc voilà et puis finalement
c'est pas si difficile de prendre un
risque une fois qu'on en a pris en
offrant qu on a envie d'en prendre un
autre challenge jacques qui m'attendait
alors on cydia et comment créer pas
notre entreprise à dos on avait bien une
idée depuis quelques temps
prendre le temps de l'incarner
véritablement et puis tant qu'à faire
allant même jusqu'au bout du bout et si
on crée une entreprise du numérique une
start up sans aucun bagage technique
particulier seulement une bonne idée et
lentilles
en fait c'est ça qui est formidable avec
le numérique c'est que faire un terrain
de jeu immense où tout est possible
parce que il ya tellement de métiers à
inventer tellement de métier a
révolutionné grâce à la technologie qui
elle ne s'arrête jamais l'avancé car
c'était pas gagné mais si je vais
apprendre à ma fille qu'elle peut tout
faire
quelle image moi je lui renvoie sa mère
si je suis pas capable de prendre un
risque pour vivre autrement
aujourd'hui je dirige une entreprise
innovante d'une dizaine de personnes en
pleine croissance
il ya quelques jours de ça j'étais aux
états unis à las vegas aussi l'un des
plus gros salons au monde consacrés à
l'innovation technologique moi qui
n'étais jamais allé aux états unis et
aujourd'hui j'ai cet échange avec vous
sur cette scène de théâtre
qui l'eût cru
alors j'ai fait ce choix en fait il ya
trois ans et je le regrette absolument
pas même si c'est pas forcément évident
entre des jo c'est vrai que le stress
est mon nouvel ami je dors assez peu
mais je suis un petit peu blanchie j'ai
fait une première couleur il n'est pas
très très longtemps
mais vous savez quoi j'aime ce que je
fais et pas une seule fois j'ai eu envie
d'un mode excuse pour pas aller
travailler le matin mon métier je les ai
inventées il exactement comme je l'avais
imaginé lorsque j'étais enfant et ça me
remplit de gratitude
en fait j'ai découvert que le secret du
bonheur c'est simplement d'oser demander
l'avis d'antoine envie et sans crainte
de l'échec parce que il fait partie
intrinsèquement du processus
je peux pas vous parler de ses amis s'en
vont parler d'une femme très très
inspirante que vous connaissez peut-être
est une américaine qui s'appelle helen
keller et kiné au début du 20e siècle
ram dans un siècle où les femmes
n'avaient pas forcément beaucoup de
chocs arrière possible
en plus de ça elle aime qu elle m a
contracté une maladie très jeune elle
doit avoir tout juste dix-huit mois qui
l'a laissée sourde aveugle et muette
il ya mieux pour démarrer dans la vie
commune malgré tous ces handicaps et
grâce à l'amour à la patience de ses
proches et une détermination absolument
incroyable cette femme est devenue de la
plus grande défenseuse des droits
humains de son temps auteure
conférencière
elle a voyagé dans plein de pays
rencontrer des grands dirigeants
charismatiques emblématique lot de 100
ans et lnk lettre 10
je suppose que vous connaissez cette
légende
décrivant la chance comme une jeune
femme capricieuse ne frappant à votre
porte qu'une seule fois s'il apporte
tarder à s'ouvrir alors la jeune fille
passe son chemin
c'est ainsi les femmes les plus
charmantes n'attendent pas vous devez
agir vite pour ne pas les laisser filer
je suis votre chance je frappe à votre
porte
je veux être adoptée la légende ne dit
pas ce que vous devez faire si plusieurs
belles opportunités se présentent en
même temps j'imagine que vous devez
choisir celle qui vont créer plus la vie
est ainsi
elle est soit une aventure audacieuse et
soit rien du tout c'est à vous que le
choix revient
n'attendez pas juste d'avoir 30 ans pour
le faire n'attendez pas un moment précis
pour vivre enfin la vie dont vous rêvez
il risque de ne jamais arriver
et quand bien même quand bien même vous
avez attendu jusque là quand bien même
aujourd'hui vous avez 40 ans 50 ans 60
ans d'autres arrêtées tout respect soyez
audacieux pour être heureux merci
[Applaudissements]